My name is John and I work in developer
relations. I'm building a party game
called the hierarchy of fruit. And this
is where you can go in and you can rank
fruit. So you can take one here. I'll
give it a two. No, I'll give it a one
right there. Leave a comment. We're
going to build this all right here. It's
a fun game to play with your friends or
your family and I'll show you how. All
right. So, how do we want to start
building this game? Now, of course, you
could start right here and give in a
prompt and start building your app, but
I would actually recommend not doing
that, and that's because if you do a
little bit of planning beforehand and
collect some assets and come up with a
plan, you're going to end up having a
better app. So, let me show you what I'm
starting with. The first thing is I
started with a concept. I already have
an app idea in mind, and it's a game,
and it's called the hierarchy of fruit.
And the idea of this game is that it
takes 22 different fruits and you rank
them. Okay? And you can do this with
your family or your friends. So you can
choose a room to go into and just play
it with them. Or there'll be a global GL
game as well. And the idea is that you
select a tier. So tier one is the best
fruit and tier two is fine and tier
three is either a bad fruit or
deceptive. And I'll give you an example
of one of those. That's dragon fruit.
Dragon fruit looks amazing, but it's
just like slightly sweet. Okay, it's a
deceptive fruit. Dragon fruit is a tier
three fruit. Okay, and that reason I
would put in here. So, when you're done,
you can look at everyone's rankings and
you can see the reasons why they did it.
Okay, so that's the concept for the
game. And I've got some simple UI here.
So, I've got this little logo. I've got
the rating screen. I've got some
onboarding screens and I've got the
concept and I've written that down. And
why this is helpful is because the very
first thing you want to do when you're
working with AI agents is give it the
overall plan. And that's because as it's
making decisions, it will always
reference that plan. So whenever the
model has any ambiguity, the context
will be the context of what you are
trying to accomplish. Okay. So, we've
got some assets. We've got the idea of
the game. And I'm not going to start
with this prompt here. Starting with the
prompt here is good when you want the
model to do a lot of work. But what we
want to do is we want to work slower,
step by step, because AI models are
great, fast, junior engineers, but
sometimes overeager, and they'll build a
lot of stuff that you might want, but
you might not want. So, instead, we're
going to do a new project right here.
We're going to call it hierarchy of
fruit and we're going to create this
project. Okay, we've just got this basic
scaffolded app here and we're ready to
start working. So, the first thing you
always want to do is give your agent a
plan. So, first I'm going to select
Claude right here. And I'm going to tell
the agent, I want you to create a plan,
MD file that keeps track of the project
description, tasks, and subtasks and app
architecture. So, this plan file will be
the source of truth for our agent.
Please create this file. Okay, the agent
is going to go create that file. I want
to see it come in right here. So, let's
just wait. It's looking at what our
project looks like currently. And now
it's going to create this file. Okay,
great. It's created this file. Let's
open this up. You could click here or we
can go up and just click on here and
it's going to open up. And let's see
what it says right here. It has the
title, the type of application. It
recognizes that it's a new Flutter
project in the starter phase with basic
counter functionality. So, it knows it's
just that basic file right now. and it
started some check mark stuff here. We
don't need any of this stuff right now,
but it'll update this accordingly. So,
we don't have to worry about deleting
all of that. Okay. So, now we're going
to give it the plan for our app. So,
I've got some copy here that I've
already written. So, I'm going to paste
it in here and I say I want to create a
game app called Hierarchy of Fruit. The
main idea is that users will rank 22
fruits as one of three tiers. With each
fruit, they'll give it a rank and can
include a comment as to why. When
they're done, there's a final scoreboard
that shows the aggregated ranking of all
the fruits in the comments. And there
are two options, a global game and a a
room code you can share with your
friends and family. And I'm going to use
Firebase for my database and
authentication. So that's my
description. And I just want right now
the agent to update the plan.md with
this information. Now notice as we're
working, the agent isn't actually
writing any code yet because we gave it
the instructions to just edit this file.
Probably the two most important things
when you're working with AI agent is one
to be explicit because the AI agent
knows nothing about you or your app or
your context unless you tell it. And one
mistake we can kind of have is that
because LLMs are so adept, we can
sometimes think that it knows more than
it does. So be specific. And the second
thing is to work in small steps. One of
the best ways to reduce hallucinations
of agents is to give it one small
contained task at a time. Okay, now it's
done here. So let's take a look at the
changes it made right here. So we have
the project description. We have the
game concept. That looks good. We've got
some features right here. We've got the
text stack. That all looks good. And as
I'm looking through here, it hasn't
decided on what state management we
need. We don't really need anything
complex. So, we're going to use
provider. So, I'm just going to delete
that and save it. And remember, because
I told the model to keep track of these
things, it will refer back and see this
change. It gave a planned project
structure. Now, it hasn't created any of
this yet. It just has come up with this
structure right now. And as we're going
through here, you can see that it's
starting to check off the different
tasks that it's thought is important.
Let's just look through here. Okay, this
is looking good except for I want to
change the list of fruits. So, update
the fruits to these. Okay, that looks
great. I've updated these. I've put them
in the order that I want. Now, I have a
font that I want the app to use, and
that's Poppins in Google Font. So I
would like to use the Google font
Poppins. All right, great. So this
updated. So we're using the Poppins.
We're already using Google Fonts. So
that's great. All right, next step.
Let's plan the schema for Fire Store for
our backend. So let's say plan the
schema for Fire Store and store in
plan.md.
Okay, that's done. Let's take a look at
what it did here. We don't have to jump
in here. We got a users collection, our
fruits, the different rooms, game
section, rankings, global stats.
Beautiful. That looks great. Okay, so
we've got our plan now. We've got our
database schema. So now we're ready to
integrate Firebase. So let's go over to
our Firebase tab. Let's connect to
Firebase and we're going to create a new
project. This will just take a few
minutes to set up. But the important
part is that now that we have a plan,
when we actually generate the code,
it'll be able to generate the schema and
the security rules that are particular
to our application. Okay, the project's
been created in Firebase. So now let's
configure Firebase. Now, one thing to
keep in mind as this is building, you
may see some errors in your project, but
those will go away. The analyzer is just
continually checking the project while
it's building, so don't worry about
that. All right, that's configured. It
defaults to three target platforms.
That's great. So now let's generate some
client code. Now you can see here as
it's planning out it that it references
our plan MD file so it knows what to
generate. All right, that's done. Now we
want to deploy to Firebase right here.
Okay, great. Now let's configure our
authentication. This is just going to
bring us to the Firebase console. So
we're right here. Let's get started. And
we'll just do email and password for
now. So let's enable that and we're
ready to go. Okay, now this is ready to
test. But I wanted to follow up on one
thing about this aspect when it
generated the schema. Now it generated
the schema based on what it knew about
my project already. And that's why we
took the time to give the agent a plan.
Okay, so let's test this out and make
sure the authentication is working
correctly. So let's sign up and let's
add my email. Great, that's working.
Beautiful. Okay, so next I actually want
it to default to light mode. So let's
have the default be light mode. Okay,
that's getting better. Okay, that's
looking great. But let me actually go
back and sign out for a second because I
want to redesign this page. And if you
remember, I have some UI that I created
for this. So, I'm going to drop this in
and I'm going to select specifically
GPT5 because it's the model that has the
best visual understanding of UI. And I'm
going to say, please redesign the
authentication
page according to the attached design.
Ask any questions if you are unsure
about something with the design or
implementation. We've published a video
on this before, but there's some
research to suggest that if you
explicitly ask for clarification
questions, the model performs better
because you as the user and developer
clarify the uncertainty instead of the
model. Okay, so it did come back with
some questions before its
implementation, which is great. So,
let's read through these. Signin versus
signup. The design shows a sign up page
with four fields. Do you also want a
sign-in page? Uh, yes. That's a good
point. We didn't add that in. So yes,
both sign up and sign in with a toggle
on brand. Okay. Bottom indicators. I see
two indicators. Are these indicators
suggesting there should be multiple
screens. That was for the sign up and
sign in. But you don't have to follow
that design. Implement whatever UI UX is
best. three. It's just asking for if
I've got the logo. I'll just say just
use placeholder. And then color scheme,
the yellow background. Uh, yes. Use that
as primary color. And finally, clear
icons have an X button while the
password fields have an I icon for
visibly. Should both be functional? Uh,
yes. That would be nice. Both be
functional. And I added in this, and
this is one of the most important things
when you're working with AI, is that you
want to reduce as much ambiguity as
possible and be as clear as possible.
That way, the model can allocate tokens
and work to more important things. So,
instead of just saying yes, I added some
clarification here. Okay, let's send it
off to do some work. Okay, and there we
go. We we've got some placeholder right
here, which we'll just replace later.
Two form fields. This is looking great.
And let's make sure the sign up works.
And the signup doesn't seem to be
working. So let's see if it says
anything here. And it doesn't. So let's
just say did you create the sign up
toggle so that users can easily switch
between signin and sign up. Okay, it
says that it already implemented it. So
let's give it a quick hot reload to make
sure. And oh, there it goes. But it's
kind of tiny and so I would like the
toggle to be easier to switch between.
Currently, it's small text that the user
has to press. Make it much easier and
larger to toggle between. Don't just
make the words bigger. change the UX.
Okay, that's much better here. Okay.
Yeah, I like that. Let's make one change
and make this button here. Let's make
one change here. And I'm going to do
this with a quick edit here. Command K.
Make the selected button black. Fully
black. Okay, great. Now, let's just test
that it's currently working. So, we're
going to turn off inspect mode. We're
going to sign in. Beautiful. That works.
Next, I want to implement the voting
screen. This one right here. So, I'm
going to attach it and say implement
this voting screen. This will be used
for each fruit. I want the background
color to match the fruit.
Ask followup questions if you are
unclear about anything. And once again,
I got some more questions. And this is
just a good example of how many
decisions behind the scenes if you don't
ask for follow-up questions that the
model is actually making. So let's go
through these fruit colors. Where should
I get the colors for each fruit's
background? Should I define them
manually? Use a color palette to
generate them or just give them specific
colors? Generate manually for each and
add them as style constants in the
theme. Dart. And I'm saying that so I
can access them and augment them here.
Fruit images. I see a banana
illustration in the design. Should I use
this tool? So that's a tool that the
model has available to fetch images for
each fruit. Use emojis icons for the
fruits or illustrations vector graphics.
Use illustrations vector graphics. I
want them clean and minimalist. Tier
selection behavior. Should selecting a
tier highlight or activate that tier
button visually allow users to change
your selection before clicking next be
required before they can proceed? Yes,
it should highlight activate that tier
visually with the same fruit background
color. Yes, users can change their
selection and yes, the tier selection is
required. Uh for the comments, this is
comments are not required and make a
seven sentence max five. After vote on
all 22 fruits, where should the user go?
Navigate the user to the results page.
Just create a blank page for now. Can
users go back to previous fruits to
change their vote? No, they cannot go
back and change vote. Should there be a
progress indicator? Yes. Implement a
progress indicator on brand. And then
finally, six, info icon. I see an info
icon rating. What should this display
when tapped? This should display a
dialogue on brand that explains that
tier 1 is excellent, tier 2 is good, and
tier three is either bad or deceptive.
Great. Okay, so that's implemented. So
let's start a global game so we can see
it. And that's not implemented yet. So
let's do that. But actually, let's
redesign this page so that it's more on
brand. Now the interesting thing is I
don't have a design for this page but we
already have some designs implemented
and I'm going to pass in those designs
again and ask it to use the same design
style. So update which page is it here?
Let's look. Okay, the home screen to be
on brand with similar style to the off
and voting pages. I've attached those
pages so you can see them again. And
here's a real interesting thing. It
followed up with some questions. Even
though I didn't ask it any questions
now, but because the agent has memory,
it knows that I like it to ask
clarifying questions. So, let's answer
some of these. Should the home screen
keep the same logo? Yes. Include the
logo. Main actions on the home screen. I
see the current version has start global
game and play with friends button.
Should I keep both of those actions? And
should they be styled like yes? Yes.
Keep both buttons and style like you
said. Three. A greeting. Yes. Use no
greeting. Four. Currently it's in a
popup. It's in a pop-up menu in the app
buyer. Should I keep it there? Move it
to a visible button on screen or styled
differently? Let's remove app bar and
just have sign out button in top left.
Right. Do you want any decorative fruit
illustrations or icons on the home
screen similar to the voting page? Um,
no. I find that uh models are not good
with this kind of ornamentation. All
right, go. Okay, there we go. A little
bland, but that's fine for now. So,
let's see. That's not working yet. So
now let's say implement the logic for
starting the global game. Now notice one
thing that I did. I could have added
this to the last one, but you want to
break things down into the smallest step
so the model can focus on just one thing
at a time. So I just want this button.
Then I'll do that one after it. Okay,
it's done. Let's see what changes it's
made. It made a game controller service.
It updated the home screen with the
functionality. Okay, that's great. And
it updated the voting screen. So, it
implements all the logic there. And then
the results screen. It accepts the
session ID and user ID for future
implementation. Okay, great. Let's start
a global game. And we're getting a
problem here. Let's take a look. Okay,
this requires an index. Okay, I created
the index. Now, let's start this game.
Okay, beautiful. Okay, this voting looks
good. I just want to make a few tweaks
here. Let's see about this tier. That
looks good, but I want this kind of over
here. So, I'm going to do this over here
so I can edit the properties. And we
have this space between, but I actually
want these together. That looks good.
And I want to give them a little space.
So, maybe 12 pixels. That's too much.
So, let's say six. Yeah, that's looking
better. and maybe add some room in the
bottom here. So, let's grab this icon
right here. Let's add a modifier, some
padding. And I don't want all this
padding. Just add some in over here.
Maybe six pixels.
Maybe some more. Yeah, that looks good.
Okay. Also, I want this button to be a
little bit bigger here. Let me check the
Now, I don't know where the height is
coming from. So, I'm going to go up in
this hierarchy to see. Oh, we've got a
sized box right here. Oh, and we can
grab the height right here. So, I'm
thinking maybe 50 pixels or 60. Okay.
Yeah, I like that better. All right. So,
let's go through here and good. Not
great. Banana. It's versatile, but not
too yummy. Okay. I'm here on my last
fruit and when I click here I get this
missing or insufficient permissions. So
I'm going to tell my agent when I'm on
my last fruit and click view results I'm
getting the fire store error missing or
insufficient
permissions. Now it [clears throat]
currently doesn't have access to my
permissions. So, I'm going to go into
the Firebase console and just paste them
in here. So, I'm in here. I can go to my
rules. I can just select all of these
and then paste them in. Okay. So, we the
agent recognized the problem here and
gave me the updated rule for the
rankings. So, I'm going to copy this and
paste that back in and come up and
publish. All right. Now, we can view
results and we need to create another
index and we're just going to ask the
agent about this. I'm no no no no longer
getting a permissions error but an error
that I need to create an index. What
index do I need to create? Okay, it's
telling me this index. So, I'm going to
go over and create that. And you can do
that by coming into indexes right here
and add an index. Okay, that's done. And
it'll take a minute to build that index.
Okay, so that's all done. The index is
made. So let's view our results. And
beautiful. So we get our session ID,
which we need. And now we just have to
design this page. So let's give that to
our agent. So we're going to open up a
new conversation thread here. And we're
going to say create the results page.
Make sure to include the tier rankings
and comments. This will be used for both
the global game as well as the game with
the room code. Follow up with questions
before you proceed to reduce ambiguity.
And not unsurprisingly, we get some
questions. So, we'll just answer these.
Okay, it's created those. Now, we need
uh the ability to see these
leaderboards. So, we're going to say on
the homepage if the user has completed
the global game, create a button for the
results page. Okay. Next, let's fix this
logo right here. And let's tell our
agent, I've uploaded my logo. Please
replace the current logo with my logo.
And I'm going to go into the code. And
here are my images. And here's my logo.
So, I'm going to add that to agent
context and send it off. Okay, great.
This looks good. So, let's see where we
are. Beautiful. This looks great. Now,
we are ready to push this to the app
store. All right, let's start a global
game here. Let's check if everything's
working. Great. Cherries, obviously,
tier one, they are the best. Lemons.
We're going to go tier two. Tier two.
Mangoes. Obviously, tier one.
Pomegranates. Way too hard to eat.
Delicious, but kind of deceptive. And
there's our results. You see our tier
ones, our tier twos, and our tier 3es
down here. And you can go in and you can
see who voted for it. And we see the
comments here. There we go. That's
great. You can see them sorted. So,
total what everyone voted and that's
great. So, there's our app. Feel free to
leave any questions you have below. We
love to see what you're going to build.
We've left links to the app below if you
want to play it.